thank you
[Music]
all right I'm gonna say I'm gonna say a
name and then everybody say the first
thing that comes to your head right away
when I say this name okay three two one
Michael J fox
the shakes shakes yeah does he shakes a
little bit yeah
I would have
said what he said but that's very
interesting what'd you say I said Back
to the Future
but you said the first thing that came
to mind so I'm just following your
direction that's totally fine that's why
I was just curious that shakes was the
first thing that came in mind I was
gonna say something and I heard him say
shakes and I was like what are you gonna
say I'll just say Parkinson's that was
the first thing came in well that's the
better way well that's the proper way
that's the PC West that's what you meant
yeah okay because Parkinson's actually
wow the fact you said this article today
is about Michael J fox and Parkinson you
ever seen this episode on Kirby
enthusiasm what did he say what did he
say what do you say no it's just the
whole bit was him like uh Larry David
lives above him uh below him and he just
was complaining that Michael J fox
shakes a lot and that was the whole bit
of the whole episode and it's pretty
funny
[Laughter]
it's fun you know he like has he's
opening up a soda for him and he's like
he's giving it to him and then he opens
the top and sprays it everywhere and
he's like yo what the [ __ ] you hate me
or was that Parkinson's and he goes no
that was the Parkinson's
it's really fun real fun it's tight good
stuff so Bart's just living in that jug
chicks
well because I just saw him on my
explore page and I forgot where he was
at and I was like oh yeah I forgot he
has Parkinson's
um but it was cool like I forgot it
almost seemed like a reunion like he was
hugging another Christopher Lloyd yeah
oh yeah yeah that's what it was it was
hugging him it was cool yeah so Michael
J fox has opened up about his
Parkinson's diagnosis and why he was
reluctant to tell fans because you guys
know he he got diagnosed actually in
1991 at the age of 29 years that is so
early so young that's like people didn't
know for years
yeah it's uh most people with
Parkinson's start to develop symptoms
when they're over 50. although around 1
in 20 people with the condition first
experience symptoms when they're under
40. so Fox is subsequently the one in 20
who are diagnosed diagnosed with the
disease at a very young age but when he
was diagnosed in 91 at age 29 he didn't
tell his fans about the diagnosis until
seven years later in 98.
why why would you oh is this have
something to do with his image because I
know like in a lot of Asian
entertainment they try to keep like the
stars single or whatever right so that
they feel more accessible for some
reason it adds to the appeal I was
thinking maybe it has something to do
with his image or him booking a little
bit yeah a little bit for sure a little
bit um I guess just to get right to it
this is actually
um a different kind of wholesome I guess
how I read it but he stated my fear was
that if they knew I had an illness a
condition that they wouldn't be able to
laugh
oh that's really [ __ ] cool that's
true yeah because it's like like a Pity
laugh and he wants to make sure that
it's it's genuine yeah oh wow because
like for Michael J fox is obviously a
huge name especially when I was like
growing up too but yeah massive wait as
soon as he got Parkinson's or like when
people found out that's like the first
thing you think of so I'm sure for
someone that was he's 21 when he got
diagnosed he said he was 29 we got
diagnosed but he didn't tell people
until he was 36. he probably doesn't
want to because then everyone's only
gonna assume that like oh you're the guy
with Parkinson's you're not Michael J
fox anymore you're just the guy with
this disease that's your new identity
yeah I think that's how people just
naturally human nature wise see people I
think it's such a cool thing that
because now that there's the Michael J
fox Foundation like it really does
repurpose the reason why somebody is
like the flagship of this
disease because it's like now people are
motivated to donate and try to find a
cure for a thing because it's happening
to someone they all admire yeah that's
true who the [ __ ] Susan B Coleman really
yeah yeah I'm just kidding that's [ __ ]
up
I was like wait a minute
but like it's true though like I never I
probably honestly wouldn't put
Parkinson's that high on the list for me
personally in terms of things I was like
oh I you know I want to donate to this
cause because this is like a hero of
mine you know yeah yeah for sure
he did say however when thoughts finally
opened up to people about his condition
that he discovered they were incredibly
receptive and Incredibly supportive the
actor also discovered his fear of the
audience not feeling able to laugh was
quickly put at ease the audience did in
fact continue to laugh and continue to
watch my work he continued what's more
speaking out about his diagnosis also
led to a whole opportunity opening up
which is basically what everybody just
said right now in the positive form
right maybe at one point he was fearful
that that would be the Precedence for
what his identity would be to everybody
else
and ironically that kind of did happen
but it was a positive thing like Ryan
said through that he was able to develop
Michael J fox foundation and like do
something in essence even more
purposeful with his life and with his
platform with his Fame and stuff like
that so it is really dope to to just
hear like a very very Human Side of
somebody who you know has been a
positive influence and really was a huge
role model during that era and
especially in that era when so many
people had little knowledge and
understanding of the science of things
like this these types of diseases are
the way people even react to it right
then the 90s were a bit
harsh when it came to understanding
things would you guys know if you have
Parkinson's or some kind of disease
would you hide it or would you just say
it and tell them nobody dude oh really
I'm [ __ ] keeping it right here hi
just because I'm a deflector right I
don't [ __ ] tell anybody anything you
don't even want to tell your doctor you
gotta be on brand what's up you people
want to tell your doctor hopefully he'll
tell me how do you hide Parkinson's
though
go ahead
I just keep it here bro
what's wrong with your hands you know
what's funny it's really keep it here
bro it's really hard to tell like when
is a beneficial time to reveal that the
beneficial times yeah it's kind of weird
it's like if you feel like you're in a
position where you can spin a positive
or like what happened with uh Black
Panther like he didn't tell anybody yeah
but if he did what do you think could
have been different other than just
people knowing he was sick yeah yeah so
it's like and then and then you might
watch the film a different way and then
he is the artist at heart so he's like I
don't want people
to have like my art be viewed in a
different lens or especially with that
film and what that film means to me yeah
and that message I think it would get
lost in translation with what he was
going through so you have to wonder like
the reason why he didn't did he go the
way he wanted to where he he wanted to
go as himself and not be like a martyr
for like the reason why some people just
keep things to themselves they just want
to keep it to just for them you know
yeah that inspired me
[Music]
[Laughter]
the thing that um is that you choose uh
how you want to be seen as an artist
Yeah because sometimes
um yeah they choose what you want to
show and how you want to be seen but you
have to be you have to know that though
like how you
but sometimes you don't know it's the
thing still like what sometimes I'm like
oh do I want to be like this or like
that but you wanna you gotta figure out
what is the most valuable and how you
want it to be or sometimes the way you
want to be seen it's not even the way
it's taken either yeah that's true yeah
that's very true yeah so I don't know
maybe
how would you do it especially for you
that's
in the your careers you essentially
right like you're a cop yeah but
sometimes I don't know is the thing
because sometimes sometimes the things
you say like affects your family or
whatever the thing you think you have
some good material on certain things
what you're you're like you know I'm
sure my penis things no not your penis
things but like say you had like a
disease or something that you were kind
of like you didn't want to talk about
but then again you could probably have
some really cool material from it don't
you think what do you think yeah but I
don't know yeah that's the thing I don't
know because sometimes share it all okay
sure what do you want to know that's
this kind of comedian though you it is
you can become more part of your act and
it's more personal yeah which is kind of
cool yeah but sometimes
it's so hard to say that I I want to be
able to say the truth all the time or
just my truth you know maybe not but
then sometimes you're like [ __ ] but this
is so vulnerable and I already people
already say like some of the stuff I say
like my family they'll be like oh that's
really I wouldn't share that you know
but you guys do [ __ ] like that too but
uh yeah I don't know sometimes it's like
I want to say it but then that would
affect my family and that that would
affect me too or whatever the thing is
you know what's the funny a funny
balance is like whatever your disease is
you have to balance it with being really
good at the thing because if you're not
it looks like you're using it as a crush
yeah it has to be extra funny yeah yeah
because the thing is like people would
be talking about suicide and then a lot
of comics would like [ __ ] on they're
like oh everybody's seeing the therapist
everybody's talking about suicide but
it's like not funny so people give you
sympathy like where you was exactly yeah
but then you got to be like extra good
or you can't talk about or else a tacky
yeah it's kind of like on America's Got
Talent there was this contestant her
name is night bird and she had terminal
cancer and she went on as a competitor
but the song she wrote about like her
life was [ __ ] phenomenal and it
couldn't be better and then um she was
in the running like to win and then she
had passed away but she was like [ __ ]
magnificent you know what I mean but if
you went up there and your song was I
yeah and that was your whole like home
story then it's kind of like you're
guilting people into liking it which
kind of like but was like William Hung
he came up there and he was just like I
have terminal cancer right now she's
like
[Music]
well he definitely was suffering from
something
[Laughter]
balance of like if you're gonna even
mention it like Michael say [ __ ] there's
already a [ __ ] proven legend by the
time he said he had Parkinson's so of
course everyone's gonna be like oh my
God I want to fight for you but like if
he was imagine if he said that when he
was what 26 it was when he first got it
29 imagine if he said that when he was
29.
yeah I mean it depends on what you've
done and how much you know and what
you've proven already
you know it's not like if a guy came up
to you on the street and was like Hey
you like hip-hop also I'm dying of
cancer you're like all right I'll listen
to it you know but
you better sound like a diamond Studio
then he just coughing coughing through
his verse what if it's the other way
around maybe it's better it's like hey
I'm dying of cancer by the way do you
like hip-hop oh that's a good segue oh
[ __ ] I guess what if you say you're
dying of hip-hop by the way do you like
cancer
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
[Music]